stop the presses gang got a special
announcement the middle class famous
tour is in full effect hey your tickets
me the bald one the long hair we're
coming to a city near you bring the
squad out it's a great way to introduce
people to the show you get to see some
stand-up you get to play a little ayg
with me in the gipperino it's a good
time hit me out yeah guys we're going to
be in atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh
buffalo detroit denver phoenix salt lake
city chicago rose man guys it's a great
time can't wait to see you out there get
your tickies now yeah welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage there is it's a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they go to be classy or
it's just a big old piece of trash i'm
your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at cody's
basement she has caught in wind okay of
the ten thousand dollar bet that we're
laying okay when we reach uh a patreon
goal thirty six hundred thirty six
hundred do you wanna wet her beak or get
in on the action what is it she thinks
that she can make it a sure thing okay
yeah she was upstairs watching ocean's
11. i said i don't get any ideas
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table it's a family it's a business
meeting god damn it we're sitting down
we're clearing the house circling the
wagons
he is the ceo of are you garbage he's
international businessman we're almost
kind of wearing the same thing we're
syncing up i mean
no comment save it for hard feelings you
want em we got em kevin james ryan
ladies and gentlemen hey gang happy to
be here thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are true
the roof true the [ __ ] roof daddy-o
also
by law federal statute this is the one i
like
youtube's cute
but this is really more my speech
statute 13b paragraph 4 of the federal
docket section 9. i must mention the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
are you garbage
a lot of money i believe it's section 12
all bozos here at set four
okay no i'm sorry oh please no uh oh no
no
special
the dates i don't know what are you
gonna i was gonna tell them what they
get at the greatest website of all time
like i do every [ __ ] episode you're
talking about the billions and billions
hours of bonus materials i think we just
hit a trillion hours of bonus house
really yeah a trillion damn no
pretty good we're like voyager out there
[ __ ] putting miles it's nice plus
they get their hard feelings
ah yeah that's that's the real show
this is a dog and pony show that's where
the panties come off
that's where the rubber hits the road as
they say
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire which i was
trying to say before and i apologize i
cut you off mr ryan especially this at
this late hour of the month
[Laughter]
and certain transfers are processing but
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good he's our little
kid brother over there look at him
little skippy give it up for tebow
mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up dudes
what up t-box i don't want to be skippy
that's too close to getting i think it's
true i did just realize how well there
we go again
more assimilation
we're all going to be the same person in
a year
we're all going to we're all going to
meet in the middle of wait we're all
going to be like 285 pounds or something
we're all going to be in even three
bills we're all going to have medium
hair
balding in the front walking around like
the ramones
yeah it's going to be a bad luck we
aren't going to play the part now that
sucks
gotta wear it everywhere yeah
holy cow but i do i do forget sometimes
you're youth
i'm not that i'm not young i mean
compared to him compared to me yeah what
do you mean you're a kid compared to me
you're a young kid without his whole
life in front of him
well you see a 32 year old man with a
skateboard now i'm a child what are you
talking about
32's young man
not that young you're like 38 36 let's
go talk to some chicks and see what they
have to say about it yeah 32
to me you're a baby
i started comedy when i was 30 though
that's how young that is to me god you
were gonna inspire so many bozo
comedians to hang in for way too long
that fat guy from ayg did it
you're like the new rodney dangerfield
he was selling vinyl siding up until he
was 58 years old and he died of a drug
overdose wearing a hawaiian shirt what
do you know about that i heard he used
to be a jockey what
ah
that's good stuff i wanted to ask you
before we get started today um
i did this the other night to the
to the
appalledness
chagrin
of my of my female counterpart over
there um
my mirror as they call it if we were if
we were on different she's not she's not
happy about that i'm sure if we were if
we were on different sides of the cold
war that's what would be she'd be my
mirror she was a russian spy which she
could be i don't know um deep covered
she could be embedded we're looking to
start at the bottom
hey listen there's this fat comedian
over there in new york who might be
successful
start working on them they want me to
start
dc l.a hey thinking about queens
bluebell pennsylvania
that's where that's where the real
[ __ ] cell was
whatever
um which i can't believe she's never
seen me do it before in the years that
we've been together um
because i know i do it all the time
because when i learned it as a kid i
thought it was one of the most genius
things that i've ever seen it was like i
think a cousin showed me okay and this
move is
when you you fill your bowl up with
cereal okay i'm listening all right been
there and they were special okay by the
way before you start freaking out both
special okay as trader joe's special
okay so it's even better for you
um
you fill the bowl
and then when you go to pour the milk
you take your hand and you lightly put
it over the cereal bowl to hold the
cereal down so it doesn't rise as you
pour the milk in
you don't know what i'm talking about i
do i've never done it i've never thought
to do it really yeah i mean you're
really trying to get every bang for your
buck in that bowl
i like a nice amount of milk that's like
a pressure cooker you're pressure
cooking special okay bootleg special
okay at dad not even name brain
mr kellogg didn't sign off on that
that's
i guess you get what i'm saying right
you hold it down so the milk can fill up
and get all the get all the flakes wet
so it doesn't and then one
no making me wet
just turn to the air and signal
that's what you like a cereal fetish
tell me about the corn pops uh i get it
i i see yeah i i mean i've definitely
played defense on the rim here and there
if you know but i've never like tried to
trash compact it down that's [ __ ]
crazy yeah i don't have a cereal i don't
have a paper weight in my [ __ ] oreos
just go back and redo it you know fill
it up
mush it i i also like some of the rough
ones at the top you know what i mean
really ripped the top of your mouth
it's like chilling firecrackers they
gotta have a little coat on them i lost
yeah you [ __ ] yeah that's dry i mean
how many bowls how many bowls did you do
as well
how many bowls of that special k
on that particular night
which not exactly are you talking about
by the way i think it's a great question
i want to thank you for asking i was
home all night um i don't know two
probably two i do too probably listen i
do oh you know what [ __ ] it i do too
okay i do though am i supposed to
believe that two
two we have listen we have those fancy
deep bowls they have now
you know what i'm talking about they're
like
[Laughter]
someone called a pot um me uh i just
listen we go back a long time nobody
hold on hold on you do too come on
everybody does nobody does one ball
seriously well as an adult listen
i'm not claiming that you did one i'm
also not claiming that you did too
i think you might think you're more of a
hat-trick kind of guy
because listen i know you a long time
right we go back sure old pals been in
the you know been in the [ __ ]
trenches together cut our teeth
right better hair lines thinner
waistlines back in the day yeah yeah
yeah uh-huh built like a [ __ ]
ukrainian gymnast you know i used to be
tight
i was there you
are
i i don't want to sound but you're a
liar you're you're a big lying sack of
[ __ ] over there
there has been times in the past where i
may have embellished the the the the
truth sure you know for the country for
the yeah for national security of course
yeah i mean i mean you got that spy
girlfriend at the end of the day it's
all for charity so let's not get stop
pointing fingers here it's for the kids
what are we doing
[Laughter]
cereals for the kids
i will say this is how as seen on tv
products get made we could be the first
guys to get in the serial weight game
yeah like what i mean what
yeah ah
will you passed and was it two bowls of
zero what that's gonna first of all
that's not what we're talking about all
right it is a
category while we're talking about yeah
i don't like this that did see well
listen this is why people who commit
small crimes don't go in and report big
crimes because they get some some stiff
like you now you're asking me where i
was last night doesn't matter how many
bowls of cereal [ __ ] all right the
question on the table no
yes the question on the table is do you
push down your cereal when you fill up
the milk no that's am i crazy
because you two don't do it every people
out there he's unraveling people out
there have to do it i'm sure people do a
lot of animals listen to this show uh a
refined no
uh toby you don't do it either
that is so gross yeah
yeah
your hand specifically
is gross because you're going to get
milk on it and then you specifically are
for sure going to lick the milk off your
hand no i don't lick milk off my hand
ice cream yeah milk goes right on the
pants
yeah i think it's cereal shouldn't be
touched by your hands ever
i said maybe if you're combing it out
you know combing it out of the box you
know you know a little tussle on top of
the head that's it when the supply chain
[ __ ] up yeah when you gotta get in
there when you gotta get in there with a
digger you know what i mean a little
excavation how about when you go in some
[ __ ] has opened the cereal and it's all
[ __ ] up i hate that
like when the bags are ripped
i swear to god my one friend growing up
his mom i don't know why
would uh i think it was because they
used to open the the
they would open the cereal like animals
when they were kids so the mom started
when she bought cereal and she bought a
lot of cereal they were one of the
families that had like nine different
cereals on top of the fridge they were
all like a quarter of the way full
but she would take the bag out
completely she would dump the cereal in
the cardboard what that's how she would
do it
that's not sanitary dude i bit into a
[ __ ] a bowl of tricks one time that
had to be
three years old that they they were they
were like jolly ranchers i almost
cracked all my teeth [ __ ] stale as [ __ ]
that yeah you know what my s i believe
my sister does it
i want to throw her under the bus but
she empties out the box into like the
tupperware into like the that's close
rubber made spouts yeah that's like
something you saw in family ties when i
was like yeah that was very like sitcom
yeah that's that's the that's the pig
that's the picture orange juice picture
of milk too who the [ __ ] does that what
are we doing you gotta throw the milk
out after that we're gonna pour it back
in you know what i've been getting into
and this isn't a sponsored post but i've
been recently getting into the past week
and a half that dropped 50.
[Laughter]
do you dabble with that at all for
seniors
[ __ ] helps with the osteoporosis
keep your regular teeth and a couple of
snackwall cookies and i'm [ __ ] clean
yeah that dropped 50 ain't nothing to
shake us
what's the pitch what's the what's the
50 i think it's just like orange juice
and [ __ ] you know
yeah it's like orange juice and tonic or
something
this guy's drinking tom collins mix in
the morning what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
that stuff's all right
drop 50 shout it out from the rooftops
it's fun
you know it's 50 less sugar
it's got some bubbles in it too there's
something's going on a little osmosis
going too much sun
[Laughter]
i think the oranges are from delaware or
something yeah i don't [ __ ] with that
it's definitely not the sunshine stage i
like a nice orange juice too
i was at my mom's house this weekend and
i thought i was like dreaming
because i cause i remember orange juice
as far as the eye can see
i must be having a fever dream
no because it said some pulp yeah i
thought that was just from the sopranos
i don't know that was an actual thing no
pulp some pulp
yeah great some a little bit of pulp
tiny little bit of pulp yeah that's too
much too many pulps you know as you're
all [ __ ] as a kid i'm still a real [ __ ]
now but i was a real [ __ ] little kid
you probably didn't i bet you didn't
like to pull i didn't and that was
before i love it that would do all pulp
you like your you like your milk with
paul that's an orange idiot
why you try a piece of fruit
[Laughter]
i used to have my mom strain out the
what yeah i'm sure i've mentioned this
before we had like a little strainer and
i would make her strain it i was a real
[ __ ] little kid ah i would have pulled
a six i was a real little i was super
[ __ ] picky and then she just would be
like
i remember sly she was she like it was
like an episode of cheers she slid it
down to me with pulpit and i said it
right back i said hey steve
as well hey honey was it your first day
how about your cheryl filled you in
where's the other girl usually takes
care of me
you know vacation or something what's
happening dude you uh got my eggo
waffles if you did that to patty as a
kid she would she would have kept you
sick
she would have pulled a sixth sense on
you a little bit of pine saw in every
oatmeal you had munchausen syndrome
you'd be up there forever
i didn't have
she'd bleed you i mean also i looking
back
insane insane that she did it but i
think she was just tired that's crazy
single mom i was the youngest i think
she was just like [ __ ] whatever
like
was just here just shut this kid up
[ __ ] strain my orange juice
real tough guy
real hard case your generation all right
now i can't get enough of this stuff i
do so i love the
sun pulp
love the pulp yeah
all right well i guess i'm an [ __ ]
with the cereal i don't know
ah
let's see what the bozos and the homies
say i get it i get it i just don't think
you shouldn't be touching that's like
putting your hand in a bowl of soup you
shouldn't be doing that it's not it's
not that's ridiculous i'm i'm just
lightly my hands are clean i just no
they're not your hands are never clean
your hands statistically your specific
hand before i've seen you with boogers i
washed them with iodine before
there is icing in every bowl of cereal
you eat i've seen more boogers on your
fingers than i've seen in my nose
you are you're a big bug man
i get stuffed up sometimes
well that'd be your mob name henry
boogers so i went over to bug's house
with the boogers the boogers i heard
booger killed him
all right
i just have one quick question go ahead
t-bone isn't that you're gonna
that much milk over the surface area all
that cereal you're gonna get soggy
cereal way faster why not and why not
just stir it once the milk's in this is
what i'm saying yeah what are you
talking about there's too much here's
what it really is all right you're good
kids i'll tell you the real story okay i
don't like your [ __ ] attitude all
right
but
what it is is
i like a big bowl of cereal i can't do
the little rinky dinky bowl so i try to
get as many
tricks in there as i possibly can sure
or
uh special k whatever you have
um
uh
and when you pour the milk in it all
falls out like popcorn so you take your
hand and you hold it i mean that's like
if you cannonball the milk in there if
you [ __ ] slowly i pour it in no no i
pour it nice
it's to get the milk on this flake
you stir you scoop you do it doesn't it
start how big what are you talking about
there's no room to stir in a cereal bowl
i'm not saying stir it like you're
[ __ ] the wicked witch of the astoria
how big are your cereal bowl what are
you using
old tv i don't eat cereal typically
you got a box in the house i never do
there's not a box of cereal in your
house right now there's not if you don't
have a box of cereal in house you're a
psychopath uh toby you
yeah what do you have i have uh like
honey bunches of oats i think that's
respectable no it's not what what you're
doing cereal you're not going you what
honey bunch of what are you my grandma
how many bunches of oats are all right
get out of here you know it's not too
shabby either every once in a while
grape nuts ah you're gonna think i'm
crazy
grape nuts with some milk and a little
bit of sugar you probably like raisin
brain too oh yeah what two scoops [ __ ]
two scoops
i've never heard someone
brag like a rapper about the scoops in
their sierra that's two scoops
[ __ ] i'm gonna tell you what
kellogg's they coat them [ __ ]
and sugar too they don't [ __ ] around
[ __ ] kellogg's raisin bran let's go i
can't do the i can't do the cereal at
the house cause i [ __ ] have a problem
oh i'm not saying that we keep that box
of cereal was taken away from me that
night and hidden
after my third bowl i see i knew it yeah
[ __ ] two-bolt to get out of here
two-ball i'm a three-bull man this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy relationship take work we
all know that
a lot of people will drop anything to
help somebody that they care about but
how often do you do that with yourself
this month better help wants to remind
everybody the most important
relationship you have in your life is
with yourself whether you're hitting the
gym you're getting a new haircut that
you wanted doing something to make
yourself feel better
you are your greatest asset and you got
to make sure that you take care of
yourself the way you would for other
people yeah guys better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and can you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours give it a
try and see why over 2 million people
have used better help online therapy
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and all you garbage listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-dot-com
garbage do it yeah let's talk about
hellofresh hello fresh come on you know
them you love them everybody loves hello
fresh with hello fresh you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip the trips to the grocery store
count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy saves time saves money
saves
lifestyle it's worth it plus
everything's pre-portioned and we love
the recipes they got a cajun shrimp
that'll blow your hair back baby i ain't
lying yeah uh hellofresh has fit and
wholesome recipes for satisfying and
nutritious meals that you can feel good
about with six recipes per week to
choose from including low calorie and
carb conscious options
warm yourself up from the inside with
our limited time recipes including
closing cozy classics from around the
world like beef tenderloin and cheese
fondue oh my god patties on them by the
way or miso sesame shrimp and bacon
ramen sign me up daddy what are we doing
those hellofresh guys really know what
they're doing over there they send it to
us i mean they they it's easy peasy
you're in the kitchen it's me and me and
the lady we're in there it's romantic
we're having fun
it's fantastic so go to hellofresh.com
garbage16 use code garbage16 for up to
16 free meals
and three free gifts i'm going to repeat
that one more time baby go to
hellofresh.com garbage16 use promo code
garbage16 for up to 16 meals and three
free gifts do it yeah um all right let's
get into some [ __ ]
garbage questions
from the patreon over there guys when
you sign up for patreon we will answer
your garbage question on air best way to
do it we get hit up a bunch the emails
the dms everything but the uh the
patreons get top priority over there
patreon's a party you know what i mean
it's a good time i'm telling you uh this
one's just a [ __ ] what we call in a
business a home run this is from ren did
you take swim lessons beyond a
reasonable age
because there is a certain age
where you can't be like 16 in the pool
with a bunch of 12 year old or like six
year olds you know did you take proper
swim lessons proper
proper swim lessons
they hated me i hated them eating cereal
in a place
hold the milk down you dumb brood what
are you doing uh
the woman
threatened to sue us oh my god dude yeah
cause i would bite her and pinch her
i just remember one day and i was little
i was terrified of the water
terror you're still not the biggest fan
no
um but i can swim like the wind
um
i remember my i remember my mom like
opposite elements yeah you can swim like
a thing that's not known for swimming i
got like a fish uh
i remember my mom like holding me and
her having a conversation she's like
it's just patty it it's too much he
typically doesn't paulie's a mailman
okay
hated it
but i got past it i wasn't [ __ ]
taking swim lessons at like 25. that's a
real tough look but i also do we know a
few bozos that came up
that's insane to me and listen i know
you grow up here you grew up there you
grew up in the city you don't have
access to it
just my my fear and my anxiety i would
have that would have been the one thing
i said mom i want to take swim lessons
mom i gotta learn how to swim
you figure you have to know that i can't
fathom that yeah i don't know it's not
uh
it's not
it's crazy i can't i just remember
always being able to i don't remember
any lesson ever you had to i don't think
so yes i'm sure your mom took you to
[ __ ] saturday swim lessons you just
don't remember know about me don't tell
me i probably knocked you out and threw
you in the chlorine room
so my hair's falling out
chlorine poisoning at an early age i'll
lean him up against that shock he'll be
all right um
i i i know kids grow up and they don't
have access
i mean we didn't have a pool that's a
fun i i understand but i can't play the
comedy devil's advocate [ __ ]
new york's an island
it's not like there ain't water around
there i'm telling there's beaches i'm
telling you
[ __ ] rockaway beach [ __ ] coney
island they're all we're all resort
beaches go down there learn how to swim
watch out for the needles but you still
have a good time i think a rockaway
takes a couple people every year too
that coast's a little stingy up there
currents going this way now i don't know
but what my cousins did
is that and you'll see it on like tick
tock and stuff
a baby has naturally known how to get on
its back or whatever yeah i seen that
[ __ ] they did it with my all my cut
with all their kids the big guy did and
what do they immediately know how to
swim
yeah there's this thing where they
innate no i'm saying then you don't need
swim lessons because they'll like
instinctively know is that what you're
saying
yeah it's like this you hold them in the
wall i don't if toby could look it up
i'm saying years later when they start
to actually swim
they still get swim lessons i know the
human body is naturally buoyant i get
that
okay i don't know what we're arguing
over here i don't know why i'm telling
you what my cousins did
i don't know anymore okay all right i'm
just saying that it's that because they
had a pool and they had young kids like
babies ish or you know toddlers sure
so it's like a survival thing where they
throw you in the [ __ ] pool and just
kind of you'll think like nice you don't
know and you'll [ __ ] seal team six
training it is you know what i mean and
you like you gotta like you inherently
roll over on your back right and then
just start like kicking or whatever i
don't know i was never a big backstroke
guy more of a freestyle yeah i would
have sank right to the bottom on that
but i have seen that he's right but they
still need lessons after that yeah like
he throws them in all sudden they're
doing flips like dolphins and [ __ ] well
i mean that's that way they taught you
in lessons flips like dolphins dude you
said i might do a hand breaking
handstand sure not a bad can opener
handstand in a pool was a good time i
was just doing them down in florida
oh yeah
what you're not doing a handstand in a
pool
that's crazy not now how was the marco
polo action down here too it was pretty
good i was having a great time with the
kids in the pool
uh i was i was the kids all right i
thought you were doing it if i was at a
[ __ ] hotel pool and there was some
guy by himself
[ __ ] in three feet of water and all
of a sudden his legs slowly came up i'd
call him security little peter's
sticking out
yeah no [ __ ] uh no obviously the kids
are in the pool and i can't do a
handstand in three feet of water
that's not enough four feet whatever
yeah
pant stains are a good time though ten
feet for me
it's real easy
all right so
babies aren't born with the ability to
swim obviously sure but they have a
reflex called the brady cardiac response
which makes babies hold their breath and
open their eyes when submerged in water
and they kind of
they kind of naturally have a reflex
that makes it look like they can swim
yeah but they do know to hold their
breath and open their eyes yeah it's
weird that's like the nirvana kid
yeah he's making that face toby zoom in
everybody constantly says i love how he
never zooms in it's a big gag love it
good stuff uh yeah but i'll ask the i'll
ask the piece but i don't think i i i
genuinely don't think i you had to i
don't think so man
did were you ever on the swim team that
wasn't no that and also like that my
brother and sister did but that wasn't
something we paid for that was like
well i'll teach you how to swim down at
the river yeah that wasn't like we were
a pay for services kind of family they
kick in in your jeans
you gonna learn today boy i'm picking
you across the street from the trade
tracks
they put a sunny d and a pb j at the lip
of the deep end they're like hey little
fat kipping give you a compass and a
diving knife
figure it out
[ __ ] johnny quest over here
sonny d that was that was our move back
in the day drop 50.
i'm telling ya
you should try trot 50. it's less cows
less cows less sugar probably got
sweetener in it
is that what you're worried about yeah
okay after your third bowl of maximum
capacity cereal
that should be the name my cereal is
true to roof that should be that should
be the name of a fat guy's cereal
maximum capacity i mean what are we
talking about yeah it's probably got
sweetener in it okay drank [ __ ] 19
ipas last night oh maximum capacity
definitely has marshmallows in it
chunks of chocolate and graham can have
whatever you want
maximum capacity from kellogg's
this one's uh for michael first time
long time i love the ftlt
uh
you guys ever fell in a fire
like at a bonfire
you get high or whatever you're drunk
you get a whiff of the [ __ ] smoke it
[ __ ] makes you dizzy and you and you
go down
it's surprising that it doesn't burn you
that quickly yeah you can actually get
somebody out yeah uh it's just like a
little like [ __ ] ash on their eyes or
whatever
i've never witnessed i've seen i've seen
a buddy get a little woozy
you know what they were like crazy we
had to get a good hands on them i saw
some kid go right in
let's go right in we were
burning
like
in in our in
our area certain people that lived in
the older neighborhoods they were they
burned their leaves once they had a
decent enough size of property sure yeah
yeah i love that smell in the fall not
bad it's the best
that's like sometimes you go out like
the pocono like up towards like the more
rural there's just a fire burning like
every third house they just got
something like they got a burn pit
something cooking yeah it smells good um
but somebody threw a computer
or somebody on top like it was so that
was like an area in the backyard where
they burned [ __ ] so like we'd go out
there sometimes and just start a fire
and sit around drink some beers or
whatever somebody threw a computer or
something
on there and it was really cooking
and something was in it and like a plume
of like like green gas [ __ ] uh-huh
yeah a circuit breaker or something
and it hit him in the face dude he went
down like the riddler got him
it was [ __ ] yeah
he's all [ __ ] up yeah
[Music]
damn that yeah
tough luck beer and fire alcohol and
fire is never a good mix because you
know uh
you want to start testing the dragon
yeah you start you know
you don't respect it you always got to
respect the flag
you start throwing in a computer a
christmas tree next thing you know the
neighborhoods won't [ __ ] empire yeah
you got leaking toxic gas
big time yeah we all i remember we did
do a trail one time we did a trail of
gas to the fire
that was pretty cool we did that but
that's i've seen that gone wrong on the
youtube thing oh yeah we did it we
filled up a water bottle full of
gas and the tip got caught
the tip caught on fire we haven't had a
squirt bottle like it had like a squirt
tip on it that's a [ __ ] bomb right
there yeah i mean we pound we set like
and then we threw it in the water and
then the gas was just burning on top of
the water man talk about [ __ ] little
anxiety kippy i was i was
i was oh dude i [ __ ] like i almost
ran to the neighbors and been like help
us help us the whole thing everybody
abort you know it was a [ __ ] scene
dude we're all going down yeah it was
like
yeah it was tough it felt like laughs
[Laughter]
what is it boy there's a fire at the red
bridge go go go
that was when we used to steal a bunch
of stuff from the construction sites
they were building the houses you know
[ __ ] lighting caulk on fire whatever
christmas tree just
[ __ ] torching stuff get a can of
paint thinner turpentine dude that [ __ ]
will [ __ ] knock you the [ __ ] out yeah
hit some [ __ ] rubber burning rubbers
[ __ ] tired of plastic we used to the
two-liter bottles
and they would like [ __ ] turn into
lava dude that stuff i got some burns on
my hand from like just melting a water
bottle or something
i know it sticks on there it's like
it's it's like a sticky bomb
yikes
um all right let's see here this one
[Music]
all right this is from nicholas big
bathroom question is it garbage to paint
a public restroom stall with the door
open
yes i'm a big i treat they
i treat a public but specifically like a
rest stop
mm-hmm like you go to a rest i treat
that like i'm [ __ ] like it's
i don't like touching anything in there
so you'll pee with the door open yeah i
don't who do some of those places are
[ __ ]
dirty i like my privacy
okay
close the door like a gentleman turn the
lights down
[Applause]
instead of candles the moon
sense yeah i'm like a big uh i don't
like touching anything and a lot of
times those urinals you get a lot of
backsplash and then i just think about
all the pee that's splashing on me or
whatever can i say this and you're
stepping you can see yourself stepping
in someone else's pee then i see myself
getting in my car and being like that
person's pee is now in my new car this
[ __ ] sucks yeah so you just walk
through a little just
slightly touch the bottom of your foot
on a little puddle every once in a while
then wash it off yeah the snow is great
for that you find a patch of snow
clean clean the soles up through the
white walls real nice
what i was gonna say is
and i think this is more hygienic i've
kind of stay straight away from washing
my hands in the bathroom oh no except
except at home
i walk
at home i do what i mean if i poop yeah
i'm not washing my hands if i pee at
your house really
if i pee
i feel that's something you would judge
me for what but that's your lifestyle
and and you can do whatever you're
telling me you don't wash your hands you
don't wash your hands after you pee at
your house there's no way you're gonna
sit here and tell me as my friend for
the past decade that you sometimes i do
we're not talking about me all i said
was i'm surprised that you don't do that
anyway my original point i'm not washing
my hands in [ __ ] public restrooms
anymore i'm walking outside and using
two two squirts of purell yeah for sure
why are we washing our hands anyway
because otherwise you're gonna get
pissed in your frosted flakes yeah no
exactly i'm saying shouldn't we do away
with the washing of the hands and just
use hand sanitizer no because that hand
sanitizer won't take poop off your
fingers
i've tried
i've been jammed up
it still smells
[Laughter]
yeah you got to get some water and soap
on that that's some elbow grease yeah
for sure that's not gonna you know a
little bit of a little bit of purell
ain't gonna take off [ __ ] mud
um
yeah okay yeah
you don't wash your hand i don't even
think you wash your hands after you
after you do boom boom i always always
the boom boom scares me
what i'm throwing i'll get septus
what's it called that's septic that's it
that's if it gets into your bloodstream
or something i want to cut my mouth or
something
what
yeah i'm worried about getting poop in
my mouth
so i make sure i wash my hands
thoroughly after i poop
[Laughter]
ah that's insane i don't know what it's
called yeah when it gets into your blood
septus septus sepsis
septic stepsister
[Music]
that's bingo
septus
god damn mom always says it that
rheumatic fever you're gonna get
rheumatic fever jesus christ what are
you in wagon train what the [ __ ]
sepsis sepsis
that's what you get if you jump in the
chicago river
really yeah if you if you go into the
chicago river you immediately that you
get arrested and they put you in an
ambulance to the hospital immediately
damn
there's that much sepsis in the in the
water yeah it's nasty it's it's green
all year round not just not just on well
they were dumping all the poop in there
dumping poop i took the boat ride they
told me that oh yeah that's right didn't
they reverse the something yeah i don't
know send that back down to indiana hey
wherever
ship that down to those hay seeds yeah
we just dump it right in lake michigan
folks so no need to worry about anything
well that's what was that whatever yeah
i don't need to get into the specific
details chicago coming here oh yeah
march or june or something may maybe i
don't know can't wait may be there in
may baby get your tickies also by the
way uh
get your tickets if you're in any of the
cities where we're coming on tour the
link is in the description of course
come and see us there you go it's a fun
time it's a good time it's a good time
and as the big man would say it's a good
way to introduce your friends to the pod
get them out for a night of stand up
night of riffing night alas the whole
nine yards you know how many times i've
been you know we've done the shows and
somebody'll walk up and they'll say you
know i i didn't know nothing about it i
thought you two were [ __ ] losers when
i first walked in and i still think it
but you're pretty goddamn funny at that
point i said i saw you i is a real fair
piece of [ __ ]
you're bringing me to here i don't know
what kind of show it is you know your
belly's hanging out on stage here
i see a guy's little penis the whole
goddamn time i'm trying to enjoy myself
my friend he says hey want to come to a
new show check out the show
so bring the squad yeah
the group chat
send the send the ticket link to the
group chat hey you have a group chat
yeah yeah 11 guys in there
it's pretty good couple that are quiet
about four or five of them are quiet
yeah i mean the things that are in there
will you know get you locked up for a
long time i um
it's one of the first times in my life
where i haven't been in a group chat
the three of us are in a group chat yeah
but that's business i have all my family
that's fun but the kids are in that wait
that's fun what are you guys talking
about in the family group chat whatever
trashing you mostly
[Laughter]
my niece and nephew i would be honored a
couple of choice
that bald guy stinks why is he so mean
to hank
but yeah i don't have one with my boys
anymore which sucks
who are your boys
couple guys i don't know who they are
i've never met these guys yeah you have
who you met some of my squad
i can't name one publicly they're
private citizens
tom cassidy my deli guy yeah
the dry cleaning guy i'm pretty close
with you want to hear something i'll
tell you what
about progress i haven't been in the
pizza place so long the one next to my
house that they're trying to get a
wellness check on you
hey that lord ass ain't been in here
someone knocked on his door
i can't cover rent this month
these pinwheels are backing up
the beef petti guys starting to ask
questions
kit let's talk about babel babble come
on you know it le babo el babble that's
right baby if you're looking to learn a
new language babble can help find spy
try look at it this way you got goals
you want to spend uh less money you want
to save money you want to hit the gym
you want to do this you want to do that
a lot of people the top of their list is
learning a new language and with babel
it's never been easier yeah it's a
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions
that's pretty good uh not only is
learning triple platinum not only that's
10 plat what not only is learning a new
language a fun and engaging new hobby
but you can use it while you well you
can use it while you check traveling off
your list the whole battle process is
addictively fun easy babel teaches bite
size language lessons for real world use
i use it to sharpen up my uh deutsche
you know of course when i'm going over
there and you pick up just a little i
was using other apps i don't want to
mention them you know what i mean
because i want to get sued by these big
language corporations it's all ai crap
they're persons
they got they they got speech therapists
doing this they were telling me how to
say like i'm a little girl and stuff
which came into handy during certain
activities uh right now i'm singing i'm
a little teapot oktoberfest right now
when you purchase a three-month battle
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of three what are we doing
we're giving it away just go to
babel.com use promo code garbage that's
babel b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code garbage babble language for life
yeah can't be like all form all forms i
said all foreign
stupid i know you know who i'm talking
about they're the same people from helix
they got into the furniture business
there's a couch sitting right there nice
and comfy and cozy best couch i ever sat
on everybody loves all form yeah it's
easy peasy uh they sent it to us it came
in i put it together myself that's how
easy it is i was sitting on it two
seconds ago t-bones on it now uh it's
the easiest way you can customize the
sofa using premium materials and a
fraction of the cost with traditional
stores you get to pick your fabric uh
the color the sofa the size the shape
the legs the whole nine yards whatever
you want you get it
uh custom designed for you
and if getting a sofa without trying it
in a store sounds a little risky you
don't need to worry you get a hundred
days to decide if you want to keep it
that's that's more than three months and
if you don't love it they'll pick it up
for free and give you a full refund look
at that that's insanity good people in
all forms all form one wants to do their
part and offers exclusive discounts for
teacher students military and first
responders what are we doing all form
usa baby way to go all form uh all form
also offers financing flexible payment
plans so an amazing sofa is never too
far away and they offer also a forever
warranty literally forever to find your
perfect sofa check out all form.com
garbage all formulas offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners at allforum.com
garbage do it now back to the show yeah
what'd they say
uh i saw him the other night when he was
leaving i was coming in and
it was for parking
he was getting into his car
and so i was walking by the other night
and he's like he's like hey man he's
like if you ever uh
did you move or something dude
he's like if you ever need a spot around
this time call call the shop i'm usually
leaving oh that's how they get you back
trying to get me back in you're calling
hey why i got you on the line here we're
doing a we're doing a family special
it's like a casino when they told them
the plane didn't work trying to keep
trying to get me back in there
[ __ ] work their magic yeah it worked
they had nine slices yesterday what are
you gonna do
all night i mentioned nine different
individual slices
um
all right let's see here there with the
guy this was big this is um it's from
dean hey gang new here ever picked up
and shaking a littered pack of smokes on
the ground to see if they're if they're
actually empty
definitely as a kid sure
as a younger younger strapping buck and
then the big thing even now
uh
is like if i'm in the car and i don't
have my sigs or i have them in my i have
like there's a lot of empty packs
floating around yeah so it's like
you grab them you shake them i'm digging
through the [ __ ] glove box it's just
full of parking tickets and empty marb
lights it's [ __ ] and then when you
don't find one you're really [ __ ]
made you get bummed out but when you
really need one every once in a while
the lord shines down upon you you open
up a pack there's like six in there wow
oh what do you know what are you saying
that's a good feeling dude
yeah did you ever find i found a full
pack somewhere i had had them and like
missed cow that's too much when you find
what you need that's going to really hit
you i know but the full pack you're like
that's changes the day you know what i
mean like that's tomorrow's problem
it's okay this will give me my fix to
start playing the stock market after
that
everything's coming up kippy jesus
um
all right here this is from valerie i
haven't had a question right is it
garbage to use a spatula to clean the
snow off your windshield that's bad that
ain't good
what do you use cause this is my first
winter with the car and i got ham i got
hemmed up
two two weeks ago or whatever you had
nothing i had nothing and i knew i had
nothing next time you go get the car
wash are you getting the car wash
regularly by the way uh
yeah and what's your oil change
situation you keeping an eye on that
does the car tell you is it smart like
that uh yeah i've gotten it all i i have
like
probably another two thousand i don't do
that much driving i'm under ten thousand
in the year okay
yeah coming up on a year i'm like a
month out and i'm at like nine thousand
two hundred and twenty eight months no i
got two bad boys in the [ __ ] back of
the back i had them in the teego uh oh
uh oh you know when i was driving the
teego around had them because that's
just like a thing that was part of the
trade-in
that was most of the value in the car i
know
i'll never forget 200 bucks for that
goddamn thing 75 oh 120. i didn't know
you had the uh scrapers here the ice
crusher two things the little scrapers
stunk too
those little hand joins uh-huh you got
to get one with a [ __ ] pole on it you
know with something it's got to have the
brush yeah if you if you're getting the
[ __ ] just the scraper you might as
well be using a [ __ ] spatula
spatula's not a bit not bad though that
makes sense
you're trash for doing it but
it depends on the snow depends how cold
it is and it depends on the structural
integrity of said spatula yeah if it's
some [ __ ] tj max [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
spatula it's going to bend back like
trying to [ __ ] scoop ice cream out
with a tablespoon look like a jerk-off
um
i used i knew i was gonna be jammed up
i knew it because i knew i didn't have
one in there because it's the first
winner with the care
and uh
i took my dustpan and brush and cleaned
off
the snow with the with my dustpan and my
wife had the pan and i had the brush
this guy's out there vacuuming his wings
got the shop back out morning tommy
[Laughter]
three inches last night uh yeah i felt i
knew i was gonna be trash and now i got
the [ __ ] the dustpan still in the car
we don't have it in the house there's
[ __ ] dust everywhere i remember
boy do i remember i don't know where we
were i'm gonna order one today we were
somewhere there was some kind of
miscommunication because my parents are
usually pretty good with that stuff they
keep all that stuff stocked and loaded
and all that crap rock salt in the
[ __ ] back of the car and all paranoia
uh anyway must have been transferred to
the other car we took a car
coming out of some store it had snowed
it's [ __ ] freezing cold my dad's got
nothing
[ __ ] scraping the windshield with his
credit card that my dad
sat inside
in
horror
panic he was hot that night uh-huh yikes
i used uh
goddamn [ __ ]
cd case works pretty well and they was
always they were always disposable in
the early ah cdk cd case was great
even a cd from time to time if it was a
shitty mix or like an old memphis bleak
album or something
you sacrifice it for the ride you know
what i mean
and you also i mean you didn't get you
didn't go [ __ ] crazy with you just do
what you had to do and let the
defrosters do the heavy lifting you know
what i mean which they do a lot you just
got to get them started yeah that's the
problem with them tesla's now
they don't have an engine
so the snow doesn't [ __ ] melt off the
car
[Music]
that's what they're running into
because there's no engine in the car
take that nerd boy look at that so it
stays on the car like obviously there's
defrosters on it
but it doesn't yeah wait i thought they
had like things with all the snow melts
off all the car what yeah you could hit
a button and like it's like like a
heated seat but the whole car i've been
looking over there on that tick tock or
whatever and that's that seems to be an
issue really mm-hmm old chevy let it
warm up
yeah my chevy loom dude that thing was a
[ __ ] tank what are you saying t-bone
not to be mr debunker guy but
the tesla app has an a snow melting
feature all the way he takes everything
this guy yeah i just watched the yeah
wow
oh cut this
look at you i'm not gonna look like a
jerk
i've been proven wrong like nine times
anti-electrocard disinformation right
here but they're half that's n have
although i watched a guy complaining
about it fall fake news oh a guy lying
on the internet no [ __ ]
hey nice to see you
hey i admitted to the three bowls of
cereal
so what
come with me
[Laughter]
fact check my fact checker um all right
this one this is a girl this is this is
a good debate which i don't
i don't know where i fall on i think i
know where i fall on this and i'm
uh i've been both of these guys this is
from jay uh
what is more garbage
who is more garbage in the saying
you fly i buy
the guy going to the store or the guy
paying
it's got to be the guy going i think
right because he's typically
more broke hold on hold on hold on hold
on i was a big flyer for a long time say
say the the actual question one more
time for me who is more garbage in you
fly i buy
okay the flyer or the buyer the most
garbage is
i'll fly you buy
that's the trashiest when the guy who
has no money pitch cause i've been that
guy you pitch i've pitched to somebody
with money hey want me to run and get
your pack of smokes
really yeah
working in kitchens and stuff like that
nobody had barney's or things were tight
you wait so you're offering your flying
services yes that's bad real bad that's
the worst hey i'm poor can i have some
of your stuff that's what you're saying
i'll go get it here for tank and geese
i'll go get it
wow now i'll buy you fly
you're that guy
your class you got a couple of fajrolls
on you yeah you're you're the guy you're
never going to buy and fly bitcoin you
know what i mean you're all it's all
it's always like coke a six-pack
bernie's it's never something classy
yeah
yeah i've been i'm not buying them
flying to get [ __ ] healthcare
run up and grab a round at the bar
yeah i'll buy you fly mm-hmm yeah it's
try that's a good one it's a good one
it's got to be the flyer
obviously it's not even a question what
are you talking about the guy who's
buying he's he's got the money and he
has people in servitude
they're working for yeah but there is
something a little you know [ __ ]
uh it says lazy yeah i mean but it's
like kind of
dismissive a bit because when you're
going very dismissive yeah which is not
a classic it's very dismissive it's like
because people would do it to me be like
hey run down and i i mean you know i
didn't have a right away sir yeah i
never i didn't have a choice hop hop on
the double you know you just gotta
[ __ ] do it
look alive out there okay i'm running
from [ __ ] running down with two cases
of beer
15 boxes of pizza
yeah it's tough tough luck but but the
same as a whole is trashy
of course let's go get let's run to the
liquor store and get beer that's what it
should be
let's run and get an 8-ball okay
where uh you shouldn't be saying i buy
you fly that's a that's inherently trash
all right i'll give you this yes okay
you're right because it's usually the
loud cousin or aunt uncle or somebody
that rolls in that's looking for looking
to make a deal well i got no beers huh i
tell you what i'll buy you fly huh yeah
okay yeah
yeah it's trash
put in the book
trash
this is another one this is from tyler
uh florida man here new patreon just
says beer on ice question mark
and he backs it up which would i get you
got to think florida i think it's sort
of nice and classy after a long day of
work it also sort of slows down the beer
consumption modelo on ice
i don't understand what do you mean he
pours it over ice yeah ice oh i thought
he meant beers on beer's on ice is
beer's in a cooler
like ice i thought the guy had a cooler
waiting for when he got home no on ice
yeah um
i don't know i
you know
in this fusion age
where we're mixing
cultures yeah
no it's as far as like cuisine because
the reason i say that is because
i see a lot of people drink uh bloody
mary's with beer instead of vodka sure
things like that the mimosa the [ __ ]
um
the mules now you know the like the
moscow mule
everything's mixed together
you know they're sangrias and all this
stuff
i don't know where you're going with
this i'm saying it's very it it it lends
itself to that that the the trend of
fusion
these days
it makes cause if you put a splash
you're telling me ice in beer is fusion
i'm telling this
it's dirt bag [ __ ] it's what it is if
you splash a little lime in it or
something like that and a touch of
pineapple to a clam a reader yeah then
it's some [ __ ] that's different i'm
talking about a [ __ ] poor's light
of course a
coors light on ice
if you have it in a wine glass i think
you're okay
my buddies that's crazy my buddy's
grandmom used to do it uh my mom died
she would drink course she'd have like
three quarters lights a night and they
were on ice and we tried it one day
because we were all we were in college
we're all like what's she doing it's
crazy i gotta tell you we had one on a
hot summer day it was all right
it's like any town usa baby watching the
tide roll out you know yeah that's
that's right it's all right my point is
is that everybody's mixing everything
together
these days culinarily
all right why can't you put ice and beer
that's what i'm saying it's but like
isn't it is it a culinary maybe maybe he
puts a little lime in there yeah that's
still beer you're supposed to do that
breaking the rules doing things that you
normally people think you're making a
big jump here
well
well i tried
this guy this guy paying you on the side
or something
i told him i'd get him off
i wasn't a couple of free t-shirts for
him too
um
how do you not get what i'm saying
how do you not i understand that's the
first step into it i'm saying if you
added another juice or something to it
but it's not it's ice that's what i'm
saying you're going if you added more
stuff and we're not saying that it's ice
on beer that's wildly different than
like if you poured grapefruit juice in
it that's
now that would be refreshing
yeah
fine the germans do this it's called a
raddler it's like half beer half
lemonade oh my god on a hot sunny day
does that have ice no
all right take it easy
that's great what
tough guy huh well i don't know that's
what i'm talking about there you go yeah
that's i understand you you're talking
about another thing
ice is a thing
that normally wouldn't go in beer yeah
but you're talking about stuff that adds
for taste it's a progressive approach to
beer that's what i'm saying
okay sure all right so you is it classy
or trashy it's trashy okay
but kind of what's what i don't know
what we're talking about here this is
it's got a couple rattlers and talking
over huh he asked if you if you put beer
ice and beer is trashy and you were like
the sushi burrito was yeah insane
you took like the most insane stance i
like the sushi burrito
[Laughter]
but at least toby gets where i was going
with it i just wanted to be understood i
also too understand and you're talking
about a completely different subject
i think they're related and i'm telling
you they are not there's a thin
connection there nothing about you was
thin
there was a thin connection no no no no
no no no no
majority rules here d-bone says you're
out well he said it was in medela so i'm
gonna assume there was a lime in it
which means there is a second thing in
no modelo and corona in line that's
that's all you're reaching here and
you're wrong and you know it two bowls
of cereal okay
[Laughter]
my ass
your mother's ace um
all right let's see
this one's from your mother's butt don't
think that's his government name uh ftlt
never had a question read ever own a
boomerang
man that kid's good i gotta give you
that
i i'm still gonna go i'm sure there's
i'm sure there's video and scientific
evidence to prove me wrong but there is
no way those things actually work i
think they do
they can [ __ ] you up too but do they hit
you what do they take birds out of the
air what's the main purpose for a
boomerang is it a weapon or a toy
they've killed dinosaurs i think i don't
get it
there's no way i can hit a bird and then
come back to you it's definitely a
weapon for sure it's a weapon believe so
it's a weapon started out as a weapon
then became a 70s american recreational
activity shout out to dundee you call
that a knife
great movies both of them were that was
just crocodile one d and crocodile
crocodile dundee too let me tell you
something that paul hogan he's a hell of
a [ __ ] actor yeah was he always an
actor wasn't he something else i feel
maybe a badass tough guy i feel like he
was yeah maybe i don't know is he like a
rugby player or something maybe
rock band probably did it all he didn't
do much after that did he he was really
just done over there yeah over there
right yeah i think he did his thing over
there he had a movie um pretty well
alligator dundee pretty well well after
his prime was an independent film i
can't remember what it was but
cutie cutie yeah tan skin blonde hair
yeah him and the missus
lisa kowalski or something like that i
don't know her the lady that was in the
movie with her ah that's his wife
fantastic time or was it an on scene on
set romance i don't know what am i
[ __ ] danny devito i don't [ __ ]
know does that have to do with anything
he was around around
they probably knew each other yeah they
probably did
sure people hey boomerang what are you
doing jesus christ hey bed bugs let's go
yeah no no longer [ __ ] danny dial-ups
over here what do you got we just riffed
for nine minutes on hogue paul hogan
over here bed bug free uh it's used for
hunting i was trying to find what they
hunt with it it's gotta be birds you
can't be taking down a zebra with a
[ __ ] boomerang they're pretty heavy
man
i'm telling you they're pretty heavy and
they're pretty nasty yeah there's two
types there's the returning boomerang
and then there's the heavy bike that's
just a [ __ ] just a wallop something
yeah blackjack it's a blackjack for the
sky
yeah dude you throw it hard [ __ ] i get i
get that but how there's no way you can
hit something and then return to you so
there's but then what's the return one
dude just for fun no these are funsies
the idea is that if you miss it come it
comes closer back to you so that you can
get another shot idiot
you'd never make it in the bush would
you
okay you're gonna pull back from that
he's gonna make a couple of two tree
jokes there that i had
had to pull an e-brake on
uh i've seen one in person
of course
i'm sure you have i've seen one i've
been to a [ __ ] outback steakhouse now
let me tell you something do you
remember when nerf came out with those
the the the three that
had three things on it there yeah
it is thought that
that's
that the shape is helpful
for returning boomerangs makes it useful
for hunting birds and small animals yeah
now
is it true or is this like you know
australian lore
do they real can you well they really
come back and you can catch them
like are they that
they're so the ones that you hunt with i
don't think are that are that good but
the performance ones correct well and
like you can throw it in [ __ ] can't
perform it
what the [ __ ] you know put a spoiler on
his bad boy maybe a cool paint job oh i
think they're like boomerang halftime
shows and [ __ ] like that really a rugby
match
or like at a football game
i never seen that at the packers game
[Laughter]
not at the beers
[Laughter]
i don't know where you do that my friend
but it ain't over here i could take it
uh i think they would [ __ ] you up oh i'm
sure
but i just i mean the effect the if i've
never i've only ever seen them in
[ __ ] crocodile dundee or what i've
never you know never been in a street
fight and someone put out a rang on you
i wanted a bow and arrow when i was a
kid kmart sold a red one that was like
yeah you know that red one with the
skinny had one oh that thing was lethal
um
a couple buddies had that wanted that
managed to smuggle in a chinese star
at some point i don't know how i had
that wanted numb chucks never got them i
had the fake nut that the the fake
nunchucks never got the crossbow didn't
have like the plastic ones with the with
the padding on them they were like you
know you get a like [ __ ] party city
or whatever oh yeah
sure halloween okay i'm sorry the [ __ ]
we're talking about weapons okay i'm
arming myself here sure
i uh
i really wanted um
the wrist rocket
never got one of those going over this
is where you called me a bad kid i had a
wrist racket i had a blow gun at a
paintball gun bb guns m80s
blow gun's insane
yeah that's insane pennsylvania or not
uh not the state fair the flea market at
the racetrack on street road
you go out there about 15 bucks you get
yourself a blow gun had a little
paintballs oh yeah they got an
engagement ring there one year
[Laughter]
that knives i was big on knives we just
talked about this but i was big on
knives of course yeah good stuff all
right let's do one or two more than
ripper up over here
this is just an of course this is from
george ever held the wheel from
ever held the wheel from a passenger
seat while the driver hits a pipe that
was as a child exclusively [ __ ]
of course
small you know [ __ ] yeah courtesy to
the driver cruises or whatever you know
but i remember doing it when i was a kid
and my dad was like [ __ ] with his
coffee or something like that
and my mom take the wheel for a second
yeah grabbing the wheel that was always
a rite of passage because that was
always like an adult you went from you
went from turned around while we weren't
but most kids you went from turned
around in the back seat to face forward
in the in the back seat to the front to
the front seat
then to
hey
hold the wheel were you big on seat
belts as a family huge really yeah my
paranoid
seat belts all day never never never at
a certain point in the 80s no we didn't
know about them even in the 90s we'd be
we'd see a cop or they did that clicking
her ticket my dad would fake put it on
you know they would sometimes they'd be
standing at intersections when they did
click it or ticket pennsylvania did like
this initiative to
every driver has to be buckled
we would just [ __ ] fake it you too
yeah man he's showing you the ropes huh
she
knows how to game the system
now flick your cigarette at him
ask him if you've committed a crime
[Laughter]
if i've committed no crime can i please
leave
am i being held for anything am i under
arrest sir
dirtbag yeah
all right good stuff good stuff gang we
love you love you come out and see your
show yes sign a pretty old patreon
subscribe on the youtubes there yeah
also the clip channel we just uh we got
with the clip channel's up and running
that's gonna be cranking out we got new
guy luke cranking our content on ad
every week sign up for the [ __ ] clips
channel hit the clips channel we got a
lot of fun things coming down the line
here we appreciate you we love you and
we'll see you next week
peace